bonjour à tous bienvenue sur la chaîne
de vulgarisation des instances
politiques
la chaîne qui vous explique en cinq
minutes les détails des organismes et
politique en france
aujourd'hui on va parler du parlement
les sénateurs et les députés ont déjà
été présentées dans les vidéos
précédentes c'était des vidéos
volontairement similaire pour bien
montrer les différences et similitudes
du sénat et de l'assemblée nationale le
parlement
c'est des élus qui représentent les
citoyens qui légifèrent ça veut dire
votent les lois et contrôler le
gouvernement
mais le parlement c'est quoi exactement
c'est l'assemblée nationale ou le sénat
est bien le parlement c'est l'assemblée
nationale et le sénat
c'est pour ça qu'on dit que le parlement
français est bicaméral be pour deux et
caméral pour chambre il ya la chambre
basse qu'on appelle assemblée nationale
et la chambre haute qu'on appelle le
sénat
ces chambres ont pour mission de créer
modifier et voté des lois de participer
à des groupes de travail qu'on appelle
commission parlementaire pour valider
les futures lois parfois les députés et
sénateurs travaillent ensemble dans les
mêmes commissions on appelle ça des
commissions mixtes paritaires
elle regroupe sept députés et sept
sénateurs et se réunissent si les
députés et les sénateurs n'ont pas pu
tomber d'accord sur une loi à voter
chaque assemblée peut donner son avis
qu'on appelle résolution sur des projets
ou propositions d'actes de l'union
européenne le rôle du parlement est
aussi de contrôler le gouvernement
pour ça il peut utiliser des outils
comme les missions d'information où les
commission denquête les questions
écrites ou orales
la haute cour pour voter la destitution
du président de la république ou la cour
de justice de la république pour juger
les anciens membres du gouvernement le
sénat et l'assemblée nationale se
réunisse aussi en congrès pour voter une
révision de la constitution
écoutez une déclaration du président de
la république est autorisé l'adhésion
d'un état à l'union européenne
quand on voit toutes ces similitudes on
pourrait se demander pourquoi le
parlement français est divisée en deux
chambres
alors qu'elles ont plus ou moins l'air
de faire le même travail de création des
lois et de contrôler le gouvernement
on pourrait se dire que c'est une perte
de temps à cause des navettes des lois
et une perte d'argent à cause du fait
qu'il y ait deux chambres mais s'il y a
deux chambres c'est bien pour une raison
c'est pour équilibrer les pouvoirs pour
éviter qu'une seule chambre abuse de son
pouvoir en votant des lois qui la range
ou en contrôlant le gouvernement
seulement dans son intérêt lui en dehors
des petites différences comme le nombre
de parlementaires dans chaque assemblée
leur lieu de travail ou l'âge minimum
d'élections les deux chambres ont aussi
de vraies différences
d'abord le mode d'élection l'assemblée
nationale étaient tous les cinq ans au
suffrage universel direct
alors que le sénat est élu de moitié
tous les trois ans au suffrage universel
indirect
ça veut dire que les français élisent
directement leurs députés alors que pour
les sénateurs
c'est des grands électeurs qui
choisissent les députés les sénateurs
les conseillers régionaux
les conseillers départementaux des
délégués des conseils municipaux et du
coup ça crée encore au moins quatre
différences les députés étant élus par
l'ensemble des citoyens doivent
représenter la nation toute entière
alors que les sénateurs élus par leurs
représentants des collectivités locales
doivent représenter ces collectivités
locales comme parmi les grands électeurs
il y à une surreprésentativité des
conseillers municipaux des milieux
ruraux et que les milieux ruraux sont
traditionnellement plus conservateurs le
sénat est souvent plutôt à droite comme
les députés sont élus directement par le
peuple
ils sont souvent plus médiatiquement
exposées la plupart des gens ont déjà
entendu parler de leurs députés
mais très peu connaissent leurs
sénateurs enfin les élections
législatives
celle des députés donc se déroule à
chaque fois juste après l'élection
présidentielle
ça fait qu'il est très probable que la
couleur politique du président soit la
même que celle de l'assemblée nationale
et c'est plutôt logique les citoyens qui
voudraient une politique de droite par
exemple votre et probablement pour un
président de droite et une assemblée de
droite ça a pour avantage d'éviter ce
qu'on appelle la cohabitation entre un
président de la république et son
gouvernement qui ne sont pas de la même
couleur
mesalles désavantage de donner un
pouvoir encore plus important au
président de la république en ce qui
concerne le vote des lois
la première lecture et la plupart du
temps répartis équitablement entre les
deux chambres
mais les lois d'organisation des
collectivités territoriales ou des
instances représentatives des français
établis hors de france sont d'abord voté
au sénat
les lois de finances et de financement
de la sécurité sociale pass elle d'abord
par l'assemblée nationale aussi
si même après la commission mixte
paritaire un texte n'est toujours pas
adopté
le gouvernement peut demander à
l'assemblée nationale de décider pour
tous le parlement à ce moment-là
l'assemblée nationale peut décider
d'adopter soit le texte fait par la
commission mixte soit la dernière
version qu'à la beauté et qui comprend
aussi les amendements du sénat
l'assemblée nationale a globalement plus
de pouvoir que senna pour contrôler le
gouvernement car elle peut utiliser le
vote de confiance et la motion de
censure au cas où le président de la
république est vacant c'est plus ou
moins la version polie pour dire qu'il
est mort ou que vraiment il est plus
capable d'être président et bien dans ce
cas là c'est le président du sénat qui
assure l'intérim
c'est ce qu'on appelle la permanence du
sénat et ça veut dire que le sénat ne
peut être dissous par le président de la
république alors que l'assemblée
nationale peut l'être une fois par an
donc voilà c'est fini pour cette vidéo
j'espère qu'elle vous aura plu et que
vous en aurez appris un peu plus sur le
parlement si vous voulez en savoir
encore plus n'hésitez pas à aller voir
directement à la source sur les sites du
sénat le site de l'assemblée nationale
et le site vie publique qui sont très
bien faits et apporte énormément d'infos
n'hésitez pas à laisser un commentaire
et à très bientôt